and I'm 17 I just want to ask you if you
wanted to tell your younger 17-year-old
self a quote what would it be at 17 the
biggest mistake that every 17-year-old
makes on Earth is they think they're
supposed to you think you're supposed to
based on your family based on what
content you consume based on your life
you think you're supposed to X you think
you're supposed to Y now with the way
the world is some 17-year-olds live in
families where they think they're
supposed to not go to college and be an
entrepreneur cuz their folks are but
maybe you love going to school
that way and that's your path and you
fear being an entrepreneur because
you've seen your parents struggle with
entrepreneurship more likely you think
you're supposed to do this college thing
or be a this or be a that or you want to
be an influencer or you're supposed to
be a lawyer bro at 17 what you need to
realize is how lucky you
are